I'm looking at something Gary yeah are
you putting up your wife's artwork on
your zoom so that her artwork will be
seen on our app and not behind you I
know I said become clean this is a chi
world decision um the TV people asked me
to go around my house to look at
different stuff to put up and everything
that I could put up needed to have like
a trademark or we couldn't clear so
finally I said you know my wife's not
working I didn't put that up and I don't
know it's aggravating man I look Mary's
artwork yeah I mean everything you do
aggravates me what a grab AIT's me I
love Mary
it's funny because they do draw
attention I like you better with a blank
wall now I'm staring at this what is
that a picture of a penis your wife
painted over there London oh no that's
my oh dear I am except my microphones in
an old radio oh it's a microphone it
looks like it was it two microphones I'm
on top of your head yeah when it wasn't
you don't know exactly what it is
yeah Gary it's not a good look can you
imagine Gary walking around the house
trying to figure out what he can poop on
let me see
Owen has a trademark what does he mean
everything feels great search and all I
could find was Mary's outlook I mean
there's stuff like um there's
rock-and-roll photographs a for instance
but say yeah I don't own I don't own the
photo I say [ __ ] I'm calling
[ __ ] oh and then a lot of my stuff
was reflective a lot of my stuff was
glass and now excuse me Mary do you have
any paintings well you have non
reflective glass and we own them no
that's part of the problem almost
everything I have in the house is under
glass you know is framed yeah and so
that wasn't working as of this big light
coming on me oh here hey here's Gary
puppet did you like the pictures my
penis over by the side yeah Gary if you
could hang anything you wanted
behind you what would you have hung a
John Oates poster from the album h2o or
maybe the picture disc of man
you know what's weird about you Gary
puppet you look more professional than
the actual Gary I really do I mean the
way you dressed when you carry nothing
behind me look no copyright infringement
see Terry would you mind if I replaced
you with the Gary puppet I have a party
have a party
you